okay so the printer is finished is
bidding out all six pieces for the back
here one here two three four five six
models and little sockets for magnets
the most satisfying thing in the world
here I think they're here
I think them here down there they've
like a state-of-the-art electric
skateboard Australian company they
started off as a DIY build your own
electric skateboard company they sold
the motors the speed controller boards
the battery and you would put this all
together then they had their first part
the Raptor one but then thanks to the
last five years you're just like
developing this monster of a skateboard
like literally nothing else on the
market and close to this new fad vited
them over just because I wanted to write
it to try this thing the 2020 I feel is
like a baseline 20 miles an hour 20
miles of range that's what I would like
oh my god today oh yeah
[Music]
my hair sticking out I'm Red Hood
how much sticking out there you go go
yeah but this my head dissing it it
actually worked actually spent the last
night working in this D he busted up his
epoxy sculpt he just kind of takes a
little printing error in the nose here
so now we have the helmet another
segment attached it all together first
thing is tape to hold everything in
place after ended the friction welding I
use a drywall compound to kind of go
over the ridges here and smooth them out
a little bit and I will sand the heck
out of it and then paint it well plan it
and then paint it who knows what I'll do
with it when it's all done maybe I'll
take some cosplay photos or I don't know
I mean no one really cares about Red
Hood the Joker was a first Red Hood but
that's all out war ruined by Alan Moore
it was his origin for the Joker but he
doesn't count it as a real ordinance
Joker has no real order I think so yeah
yeah it's Robin Jason Todd he supposedly
died bring him back with the Lazarus Pit
goes crazy becomes rid of it and he
kills people that's why you things like
that also better so here's what happened
we were out in Chinatown we were walking
down the street and Nick walked by a
couple of swords from a popular video
game and kind of like a ghost gotcha
he's trying to get me and then you
didn't want to do any push-ups on the
street peanuts streets in LA Street yeah
it's dirty but you can do push-ups with
your knuckles so then he gets in the car
and then we get out of the car here and
he doesn't want to do them on the street
here either so there needs to come
inside and for every time you move a
double gate to do 40
Red Bull it gives you wheels is this
what this is are we are responsive our
Red Bull analysis is that what this
means we don't know we're doing
battlegrounds video and I heard
rumblings that we're going to be
sponsored by Red Bull for that this guy
knocks and it's like hey someone order
some red Bull we're like no he's like
well too bad here's some red Bull so can
we like actually start drinking these
right now or do we have to wait I'm done
yet
sorry here's the drywall compound to
fill in the seams and then did the XTC
3d resident over that palm sanding it
all down the drywall didn't hold up the
seams start the show through managed
using wood putty so it's basically this
like gooey kind of play-doh it's
actually purple until it dries into
drive so I put on the helmet actually
got my fingers a little wet to kind of
smooth it down and then just did a
relatively expanding path and then a
light primer pass because you can really
see your imperfection on the service
once you use primer and it's actually
looking pretty good fill in the gaps
pretty well like there's a bit of a gap
here which is pretty smooth now this is
all pretty smooth so there's still some
slight bumps in here from like I haven't
sanded everything down fully like this
part needs a higher grit pass right
there we spend a little more time
actually standing it getting it smooth
problems are going to gotten Monday
Tuesday Wednesday next week shooting I
leave on Thursday to go to the Boundary
Waters so it's gonna be like two weeks
before I finish you know I want oh I'm
going to I'm gonna paint it right now
and so I don't know what its gonna be
finished but if you subscribe you will
make sure never to miss it
at some point randomly surprisingly
finished helm able to pop up in the
video we recently got this board and to
be completely honest it's fantastic mmm
it's dead silent I don't know if you
have the remote for it anywhere they
advertise like ten miles around Tom
powers like the v2 boost support because
I use this transport like I need high
quality metal I mean everything needs to
be as high quality as possible I started
skating when I was 10 I'm real serious
about it so we've got the most powerful
director axis and the batteries larger
capacity than any other Road board you
can buy a Jason puts his heart and soul
into design
I would love to be in a the mode is like
custom build the first obvious thing
about this is the handle having written
lots of boards and carrying the
one-wheel all around this is probably
the best feature well how about you also
have like the kickstand in the back
which is I'm going to shopping that
daughter or adults instead I woke up
well you me that easy
ready to read corner on the street and
you got a turn like most boards you've
got to go like this yeah so now if we
look at the underside of this thing also
it's not heavy it's the X way it's just
regular trucks you can find on any
electric skateboard but these have
engineered something very specific these
are just normal truck these are our
decision machines a big part of pop
Motors is releasing the heat because
everything's inside you they're designed
to dissipate the heat from the motor yes
so you can see the heatsink on the back
of the motor here and that's connected
to there so when the motors Hollett
you'll feel this is just as hot I've got
a digital readout for how much range now
you've got a beginner mode on the top
and then our spec mode on the bottom you
can see the width difference here yeah
he does allow us to put a lot more
talking to these motors these are the
final wheels this is the pre-production
out wheels the production wheels use a
high rebound urethane they're going to
be a lot stronger than these ones this
is an injection molded case which houses
the battery at 432 what our battery as
long as to [ __ ] boxes to pop boxes these
are the open source speed controllers
and then you've got a Bluetooth module
you've got a receiver and then you've
got a switching box and then you've got
the BMS it's all modular so if you want
to change this outfit on and need that
you can do whatever you want you could
probably get to back in to make a
four-wheel drive board
sounds like insanity yeah and decided to
perspective this battery is over four
times larger than the standard boosted
battery best way to put it in
perspective you sold a drag race video
yeah
old boards were 100% at the end of that
test booster bull was bad and this had
70% okay you know what I can't stand
anymore we gotta go try this thing here
we go I want to ride it I want to try it
I'm gonna give a team beginning my foot
I mean looking buy more red walls not
that they don't have flavored burning
well it's also at the end of the day I
try not to drink any caffeine after a
certain time that he just went for it
you know it's death a happy man in
slow-mo a happy heart is good this is
good
let's move out
we see you guys I got in them who-who's
make the first Red Bull you want a tip
no I'm okay
to be honest I don't quite know exactly
what's going on with Red Bull those are
a prop these are ours to drink to keep
us awake and we just are now going to
chemically keep you awake to make you
make even more videos for all your
enjoyment oh no what the only hit this
red balls because we've got to hook up
through some of its studio71 who has a
contact with the people of Red Bull and
since we're shooting the battlegrounds
video we figured a good way to get a
bunch of free Red Bull because you drink
energy drinks in progress so have fun
safe all night
look
got some brakes on it so I'm going to
pour it I'm starting to get mobile I'm
going to floor it they get about oh my
god because a lot of people don't think
of motors can get off from Stansel very
quickly so watch three two one oh my god
okay I've heard a lot of boards in my
time
this thing is easily the fastest I got a
handle so I can Mario caught it I think
I'm ready for full speed mode okay I'm
going to brace myself for sprinting I
hope I don't die three two one go Oh
dad's a little ding dang oh what a joy
oh okay
[Music]
I'm not even hitting something I'm
freaking out that was incredible my guys
are faster this go on 100% charge you'll
get fifty four fifty four point two
kilometers an hour
but normally forty nine point two
kilometers an hour although thirty miles
an hour top speed that was freaky that's
going to take some getting used to
yeah what huh man I want to I want to
know how you do that ha ha it's really
important as an electric skateboarder to
be able to do that because if for any
reason your electronics failed you're
going down a hill there was a red light
the call came out that's your safety so
the only way I know how to stop just
drop my foot light cost 30 K 30 miles an
hour it's not really cost of life so you
need to get real lows you got your left
hand depending if you're goofy or
regular you can hold on to the board in
this case you can hold on to the handle
then you want to start dropping your
weight over over to the your shoulder so
pretty much just trying all over till
you're at a point where you feel like
this and then you just push the urethane
as hard as you can you don't have to
touch the ground and on about yeah I got
my safety yeah I should really learn
that do you guys going to be showing
this off on the 13th of August in
Portland Oregon yeah my hometown I'm
jealous
so if anyone wants to go check it out
we're also running a competition at
every event so if you want to win a rap
the two we're going to do is you're
going to take a photo and Instagram with
the hashtag in Ocean Raptor I just
answered you ended up so you're totally
not like 75% speed you're saying you can
go like 25 miles
on a charge yep
what this Oh all done where did you
purposely wherever I sorry crying out
present affable Wow
so what did you do for the black line
Google points also
Bellavia it looks so smooth he can't
even tell is made in eight different
pieces it's a very first one ever so not
too bad for you a very first one the ton
of layers of red spray paint primer fact
Thank You school really nice it'll hold
itself jokes why so you bring it to the
the puppy video right right no I'm not
because I have to pee so bad desperate
times call for desperate measures
looks like you're going to have to
subscribe to see what happens around
[Music]